la mayoría de las células del cuerpo
humano diariamente actúan de manera
normal digamos que tengo una célula aquí
esta podría ser una célula epitelial o
cualquier otra célula de cualquier
tejido en el cuerpo conforme ese tejido
crece o reemplaza células muertas las
células experimentan la mitosis y se
replican haciendo copias perfectas de sí
mismas
después estas dos células tal vez
experimentaran la mitosis y en algún
momento se dan cuenta de que hay
demasiadas células aquí
hay otras células aquí al lado
y se dan cuenta de esto y dicen voy a
dejar de crecer por un rato a esto se le
llama inhibición por contacto
univision
inhibición por
con tacto
así ellas simplemente dejan de crecer y
a veces sucede que vamos a decir que una
de ellas experimenta un pequeño defecto
y dice sabes que algo anda un poco mal
conmigo yo la célula reconozco que algo
malo me está pasando y las células se
autodestruye de esta manera dejan libre
el espacio para que otras células que
estén saludables puedan desarrollarse
así que estas células se autodestruye si
se da cuenta de que hay algo malo con
ella
el mecanismo celular que hace esto es
llamado apoptosis
para
dosis y quiero que esto quede muy claro
esto no ocurre debido a algún tipo de
influencia externa a la célula la célula
misma reconoce que de alguna manera está
dañada y se destruye a sí misma y esto
es lo que ocurre normalmente incluso
cuando hay una mutación y solo para
darte una idea incluso cuando las
mutaciones son relativamente poco
frecuentes y no sé cuál sea la
frecuencia exacta a la que ocurren las
mutaciones sospecho que hay frecuencias
diferentes para cada tipo de tejido
aproximadamente hay unos 100.000
millones de células nuevas en el cuerpo
humano cada día así que incluso si
ocurre una mutación en un millón
estaríamos hablando de que
aproximadamente ocurre en 100 mil
mutaciones al día y quizás la mayoría de
las mutaciones son algo esporádico que
no tienen un efecto importante pero si
las mutaciones son un poco más severas
la célula lo reconocerá
mirada a sí misma quiero aclarar un
punto aquí estoy hablando de las células
del cuerpo o de la mayoría del cuerpo
éstas podrían ser células de los ojos o
células del cerebro o de una pierna
estas no son células germinales de
manera que estas mutaciones incluso si
las células sobrevive no serán de
heredadas a los hijos que una persona
pueda tener
cuando hablamos de meiosis es un tema
completamente diferente estas son
células de mi cuerpo que se están
replicando por medio de la mitosis por
lo que estas mutaciones podrían no hacer
nada o hacer que las células funcionen
un poco mal o las células pueden hacerse
daño a ellas mismas o hacerme daño a mí
pero ellas no van a afectar a mi
descendencia quiero dejar este punto
bien claro
y al saber que creamos alrededor de 100
mil millones de células nuevas al día
puedes darte cuenta más o menos del
número de células con nuestro cuerpo
tiene de hecho tenemos alrededor de y no
es un número exacto pero en el cuerpo
humano hay alrededor de 100 billones de
células 100 billones de ser luz
si lo analizas podrías decir que en
promedio una milésima parte de tus
células se replica cada día aunque en
realidad algunas células no se replican
con tanta frecuencia y algunas células
se replican mucho más frecuentemente y
esto te puede ayudar a apreciar la
complejidad del cuerpo humano a veces
pensamos en nuestra economía y la
sociedad mundial como cuestiones muy
complejas y están conformadas por seis
mil millones de humanos sin embargo
nosotros estamos hechos de 100 billones
de células y cada una de esas 100
billones de células es un ecosistema
complejo con sus núcleos y sus órganos
de los cuales hablaremos más adelante
y hemos hablado de la respiración
celular la replicación del adn y como
las células se replica y tienen estas
membranas complejas que transportan
cosas al interior de las mismas las
células son seres vivos por sí solas
pero viven en este ambiente o sociedad
compleja que somos cada uno de nosotros
y esta es una nota al margen sólo para
apreciar los complejos que somos
ahora puedes imaginarte que si estamos
creando aproximadamente 100.000 millones
de células nuevas cada día va a haber
muchas mutaciones y quizás algunas de
las mutaciones como dije no hacen ningún
daño en algunas de ellas la célula
reconoce que al no estar funcionando
correctamente se convierte en un tipo de
peso muerto para el cuerpo y entonces
las células se autoelimina pero de vez
en cuando tienes mutaciones en las que
la célula no se elimina a sí misma y la
célula es deformada digamos que tengo
una célula aquí
tengo una célula y tiene una mutación
voy a dibujar la mutación con una equis
aquí está en su adn tal vez tiene un par
de mutaciones una de las mutaciones
evita que experimente la apoptosis o que
se destruya a sí misma y tal vez la otra
mutación hace que se replique un poco
más rápidamente que sus vecinas entonces
esta célula a través de la mitosis hace
un montón de copias de sí misma y esta
masa de células que esencialmente tienen
un defecto todas ellas vienen de una
célula original que siguió duplicándose
y luego esas células también se
duplicaron y todas estas son células
defectuosas si las comparas con el
tejido de alrededor se ven anormales de
alguna manera tal vez no funcionan bien
a esto se le llama neoplasma
nheo
plasma
ahora muchos neoplasmas no forman una
masa como esta a veces de alguna manera
pueden circular por el cuerpo pero la
mayoría del tiempo forman un bulto y si
crecen los suficientes se vuelven
evidentes y es entonces cuando lo
llamamos tumor
entonces si este es un bulto de algún
tipo de tejido diferenciado que es
definitivamente anormal eso es a lo que
llamamos un tumor entonces el término
neoplasma y tumor son usualmente usados
indistintamente tumor es la palabra que
usamos más en nuestro vocabulario
cotidiano
ahora bien si este bulto crece hasta
cierto tamaño solo está ahí no hacen
nada realmente peligroso no se está
reproduciendo descontroladamente me
imagino que no se está replicando más
rápidamente que sus células vecinas y
sólo está ahí tal vez creciendo un poco
pero no haciendo un daño significativo a
su entorno
entonces le llamamos tumor benigno o
neoplasma benigno benigno esencialmente
significa que es inofensivo eso
significa que es bueno si alguien tiene
un bulto y es un tumor benigno eso
significa que ese bulto puede quedarse
ahí no hace daño pero si estas
mutaciones de adn que son benignas
tienen otra mutación que las hace crecer
descontroladamente
y no solo crece descontroladamente pero
se convierte en algo invasivo
entendiendo por invasivo que no le
importa lo que sucede alrededor suyo
solo quiere infiltrarse en todo entonces
digamos que esto crece
descontroladamente y empieza a
infiltrarse en otro tejido entonces es
invasivo entonces hay crecimiento
crecimiento
descontrolado
y es invasivo y va
si vos no le importa lo que sucede de
repente se ha convertido en un tipo de
psicópata celular y peor aún sus
descendientes también se comportan así
ya no se trata de una sola célula se
sigue duplicando y pasando este tipo de
información genética dañada que hace que
quiera seguirse replicando y luego tal
vez puede haber más y más mutaciones que
dañan el adn de las células replicadas
de hecho esto es muy probable que suceda
porque algunas de las mutaciones pueden
haber dañado el esquema de replicación
del adn de manera que las mutaciones son
más frecuentes
mutaciones
más
frei
fuentes
mientras que estos se replican aparecen
más y más mutaciones y tal vez en algún
momento una de las mutaciones que
aparece permite que estas células se
separen y viajen a otras partes del
cuerpo donde comienzan a invadir otros
tejidos y a dominar en ellos por sobre
las demás células a este proceso se les
llama metástasis
estás taxis
y se refiere a la idea de que estas
células que están fuera de control de
repente pueden viajar a diferentes
partes del cuerpo y creo que ustedes
saben como llamamos a estas células
estas células que no respetan a sus
células vecinas que crecen
descontroladamente que no experimentan
la inhibición por contacto que son
invasivas que empiezan a desplazar a
otras células y acaparan los recursos
que siguen mutando muy rápidamente
porque tienen todas estas anormalidades
genéticas y que finalmente se separan y
comienzan a infiltrarse en otras partes
del cuerpo
estas son células cancerosas ahora
ustedes puedan entender por qué es tan
difícil porque el cáncer es una
enfermedad tan difícil de entre comillas
curar porque en realidad no es sólo una
enfermedad no es como una clase de
bacteria o una clase de virus que puede
señalar y decir ataquemos lo alcance
es un tipo de mutaciones en las que las
células empiezan a exhibir este rápido
crecimiento invasivo y esta metástasis
entonces puede que veas a un tipo de
cáncer y puedas decir ataquemos a la
mutación en la que las células se ven
así y puedas eliminar a algunas de ellas
tal vez puedas eliminar a esta célula y
a esta célula y a esta otra pero debido
a que su sistema de replicación de adn
puede estar dañado de alguna manera
ellas continúan mutando y luego puede
resultar una versión que es capaz de no
ser eliminada por cualquier método que
tengas entonces tienes esta nueva forma
de cáncer y luego esa nueva forma de
cáncer es más difícil de matar entonces
puedes imaginarte que el cáncer es como
una pelea que nunca termina y tienes que
atacar a la idea general detrás de él la
quimioterapia y la radiación todo este
tipo de tratamientos tratan de atacar a
las células que crecen y se dividen
rápidamente porque ésta
es la característica en común detrás de
todos los tipos de cáncer y podríamos
hacer una gran lista de lo que es el
cáncer y como la gente lo ataca pero
quería al menos mostrarles en este vídeo
que el cáncer es realmente un producto
de una mitosis dañada o más
específicamente una replicación del adn
dañada que tenemos todas estas células
aproximadamente 100.000 millones de
ellas reproduciéndose cada día y de vez
en cuando algo se daña usualmente cuando
se dañan puede no pasar nada o la célula
puede autodestruirse pero de vez en
cuando la célula se empieza a reproducir
incluso cuando está dañada y a veces se
empiezan a reproducir descontroladamente
si solo se reproducen pero realmente no
están haciendo nada malo son benignas
pero si se empiezan a reproducir
descontroladamente acaparando recursos y
propagándose por el cuerpo
estamos hablando de cáncer espero que
esto te haya parecido interesante
ahora sabes un poco de la ciencia que se
hace cargo de lo que probablemente es
uno de los peores padecimientos con los
que lidiamos como seres vivos y digo
seres vivos porque no somos los únicos
que experimentamos el cáncer hasta las
plantas pueden padecer cáncer